All right,
let's get started.
Thank you guys so much for coming.
I'm so excited.
It's definitely my honor and privilege to introduce our two guests today.
Catherine,
Dr Birndorf of the Motherhood Center and chief content officer of Goop,
Elisa Lemon.
Uh,
I am Amy Seamus.
I'm on the events and experiences here,
team here at Google.
I've been at Google almost almost seven years,
um,
but with two maternity leaves back to back so it feels long,
but there was a chunk sort of kind of missing.
Um,
as I started my other career I was a mom,
uh,
but we're here today because I actually saw Elise interview doctor Birndorf at
the end dupe health summit in January in New York City and she was on a panel
and I was sitting in the audience.
My son was seven and a half months old at the time.
And everything you were saying resonated with me,
which I'm sure a lot of you here,
same as we'll be hearing more from you.
And then I thought I ran up to a lease at the end of the summit.
I said,
we've got to do something,
a Google.
And then life got in the way and it took me a while,
but we,
uh,
you had your podcast and it was the third ever goop crowdcast and you deep dove
on this conversation of postpartum anxiety,
postpartum depression and what you're calling the motherhood shift,
which I love.
And that was it.
That was a sign for me.
I said,
let's get these ladies to Google.
A lot of people will want to hear from you and talk about this,
these issues.
Um,
we're very fortunate at Google because we have a wonderful benefits team and a
great paid maternal and paternal leave.
But that's not to say that Google isn't a very exhausting and demanding place to
work as it should be.
We are Google,
but there is a lot to be learned when we are in this post baby postpartum phase,
which is why I thought that not only myself would love to learn more.
And you know,
as I already said to you guys,
become your best friends forever.
Um,
but that everyone else would learn a lot about this particular issue and how we
can work through these changes while we're at work.
Um,
and I would of course be were missed by,
didn't mention that may is mental health month.
So Google is hosting a series of talks throughout the month of May to dive
deeper into specific parts of mental health.
I know we're going to address it a little bit in our conversation today.
Um,
but you know,
just know that mental health has a wide variety of looks and feels.
Um,
and you know,
one in five people suffer from some version of it.
So if there is anything,
you know,
you're feeling you need more out of Google and from our benefits team,
be sure to look things up this month on go mental health and look out for
different talks throughout the rest of the month.
Um,
so with all of that sense,
um,
let's get to going.
So again,
um,
I have two young boys.
I've only been back from my second maternity leave for seven and a half months,
which feels so short yet,
so long.
And,
um,
navigating being a working mom is difficult.
And,
um,
it was so wonderful what I was hearing that not only anecdotally is it
difficult,
but scientifically and biologically it is in fact difficult.
So while I had very high functioning pregnancies and postpartum experiences,
that was not the case,
certainly for all of my mommy friends.
And,
um,
so I wanna just start today with asking what is postpartum anxiety?
What is postpartum depression,
what's the difference?
And then also,
I know you're kind of coining a new term,
um,
in that sphere.
So starting,
they're starting their,
okay.
And that'll be the whole hour.
Can you chart?
Yeah.
Um,
well I think postpartum is just after birth,
right?
And so everybody is postpartum once they have a kid and there's a normal range
of adjustment.
Right?
So we were just talking about this.
Everybody has something,
it doesn't have to go all the way to a disorder.
Right?
So what you're referring to is what we're calling perinatal mood and anxiety
disorders.
P m a d p mats.
And that is the new phrase for PPD,
which people are starting,
thankfully,
to recognize postpartum depression,
that sort of the catchall phrase or postpartum people say,
did you have postpartum?
Yeah.
And that's that.
And that sort of whisper that's like beyond the adjustment,
beyond the normal adjustment,
but it doesn't capture it.
All right?
So people are missed because they think postpartum depression,
I'm not depressed,
so they get confused.
And so that's why when you guys,
when goop wanted to talk about anxiety,
I thought it was great.
It's not mail,
it just wasn't discussed.
Okay.
So,
um,
there can be normal,
like when you have a kid,
everyone gets,
you know,
things change.
And I think we,
uh,
are very adaptive,
thankfully.
And so everyone's a little bit anxious because you're taking care of this
totally dependent creature.
You may not know how,
you probably don't know how and you have to figure it out.
Um,
and so everyone's a bit anxious.
But when it goes beyond just anxiety that you can get to work,
do your things,
do your normal daily routines,
then we're getting into trouble.
And that may be in the anxious realm or in a depressive realm.
I can blather on forever about those things.
But so just know it's all,
it's normal to have a little bit of an adjustment.
How could you not?
It's like the most profound identity shift imaginable.
Yeah,
I remember,
this isn't all too intimate story,
I'm sure,
but yeah,
it's my poor husband sitting in the audience.
But I was I think three or four weeks postpartum with my oldest son and I was so
happy and I ran up to him,
just hysterical sobs hugging him,
saying it was the happiest I've ever been,
but yet I was crying and I even said,
well,
if they lose the baby weight and this will be the best.
And I mean I look back on it now like what was going on there,
but,
and again,
I was so happy.
So it wasn't anything to be concerned about at the time.
But it is,
the emotions are certainly there and so
intense.
That's the blues.
Right.
And that's almost everybody I say to,
to patients and to friends,
you're the unusual person who doesn't have that.
You described it perfectly,
happy,
sad.
We call it emotional lability,
sort of the ups and downs.
It's super intense and you feel like you're losing your mind for that moment or
for that,
those few minutes that you're not.
That's the hormonal fluctuation that that is happening after delivery and
completely normal,
just holding biologically what happens.
Absolute.
Just again,
what is so wonderful to hear,
and I normal's not the right word,
but to know that happens to almost everybody.
Yeah.
So talk about the Motherhood Center,
which opened in New York City.
How long ago?
Just over a year.
A year ago,
hopefully to be opening offices all over.
Um,
and just to note for people,
I know a bunch of you who had emailed me,
it's not just for people who are currently pregnant,
which was you are,
congratulations.
Um,
or if you just had a baby.
But if you are thinking about having a baby,
so talk about the Motherhood Center,
what it is and how it helps.
So we opened this place called the Motherhood Center,
um,
which is trying to help women who are and families trying to conceive,
thinking about conceiving.
So fertility issues,
those who are pregnant and then those in the postpartum.
So it's really the Perry needle experience.
That's what that timeframe is.
Right.
And,
um,
I know we're called the motherhood center,
but as I see men out there and I know who are dads,
I think like we really do,
we also address,
it's really a family issue.
And I think maybe that's,
we'll talk some of that later.
Um,
that it's not just about the mom,
but we really wanted a place where we could,
we've sort of turned ourselves into the mothering center.
So really helping women,
um,
go through the adjustment and the transition into motherhood.
And the dads come on.
Fridays are the partners and we have a group for just them.
And we also bring them into different kinds of family groups so that they can
talk about their experience in this transition.
But we go from,
just to tell you a bit,
it's a comprehensive treatment center.
Nothing like this exists in the country.
Um,
so we're trying to create this pilot program that we hope we can nail so that we
can make it a,
um,
a place that could be in other areas of the country helping women adjust to
motherhood.
But it's not just those who are well and having the normal adjustment.
We are also dealing with women who are just shy of going into the hospital,
right.
So who are really needing a comprehensive day program.
They,
they're just not making it out there.
They're,
they're not getting out of the house.
They're not getting to prenatal care.
They're not going to their pediatricians afterwards or just not able to function
as well as they should.
And these are high functioning women who just are so down or so anxious.
We see a lot of postpartum OCD,
that was one of the postpartum anxiety disorders.
We see all kinds of things and they're just not,
they're not making it.
And so they come in for therapies from group therapies from nine 45 to two 45
and we have an onsite nursery.
So they bring the babies and we help them kind of figure out how to be with the
baby or the two attached.
Are they not,
are they too detached?
So different iterations of,
of bonding and attachment we address,
um,
with the new moms.
It's so amazing.
Yeah.
How's it going?
It's going really well.
It's,
it's like,
it's so much fun and I think those of us who have come together so passionate
about this time period and,
and treatment that is so lacking,
there's a dearth of this kind of treatment in the country.
Um,
and I think that to see women go from struggling so much and feeling like
they're never going to be able to be the mother,
they want to be yeah.
To within two to four to six weeks walking out of there confident and feeling
like they got this,
you know,
we have graduates come back and talk to the moms who are newly coming in and it
is like goosebumps.
Yeah.
Hmm.
And you said it,
certainly the passion is there.
Once you,
even in just meetings at Google,
once you identify that somebody else's,
a mom,
it is,
there's an immediate switch and connection and people are so passionate about
this topic and feeling so feeling empowered is difficult during the postpartum
timeframe.
So,
um,
so at least to you also a mom of two boys.
Yeah.
Boy,
moms.
Moms are great,
everything's all good.
Babies are all good,
but you are the chief content officer of goop.
You have to see so much come across your desk.
Okay.
So how did you sift out Catherine and the Motherhood Center and say this is
something that we need to promote?
This is so brand,
right.
The synergies.
So great.
Um,
what was it that struck you about this that's different than everything else?
I'm sure you,
you see,
so,
um,
before actually I wish I had met Catherine when I was,
had my first child.
I'm sad that I didn't,
I was not like everyone.
I don't want anyone who well equipped for parenthood.
Um,
definitely not well equipped.
And after I had my first child,
um,
I felt really bad.
It was probably a year after and I was talking to a doctor and this doctor
Alejandro younger,
and I was like,
what's wrong with me?
Like I don't feel good.
I'm,
I'm tired of being told that it's because I have a child because I was getting
really good sleep.
Um,
and he put me on this clean program.
He was like,
let's get you more vitamin D.
He's just like,
we're just gonna like I'm just going to put something based on what I think is
probably going on.
Um,
vitamin B clean program.
I felt incredible.
I felt dramatically better six weeks later.
Um,
and in that process he introduced me to this doctor and the Australian Bush,
his name's Oscar,
Sarah lack,
and he was working on this concept called postnatal depletion.
And he was like,
there's just no,
nothing in literature about this.
But he was observing it sort of in this family clinic and rural Australia,
these women,
he would have multiple children and every time they would present it was there
were more depleted more.
And,
um,
he was like,
this is a weird,
there's,
there's stuff on postpartum depression,
not enough.
And then there's nothing about depletion.
And I did a story with him and it was incredibly,
like the response was insane.
Women were just tons of emails because essentially he's like,
he believes for seven to 10 years.
Like it can take seven to 10 years to recover with women start in a sort of
depleted state already.
They,
even if you have the best intention to eat perfectly,
like I don't know anyone who does,
like,
and our food is not amazing.
And um,
you sort of start behind the starting block.
You have a child,
they take everything that they need from you,
all the fat in your brain
and you end up worse off.
And we all know from having a baby that you go to the doctor a lot and then as
soon as you have the baby,
no one cares about you.
You have like one checkup where they're like,
looks fine.
I think your abs aren't separated.
You cannot have sex with your husband.
See you in a year.
Yeah.
And,
um,
anyway,
so did story.
People were like,
this is me,
this is like describing the last decade of my life.
Um,
this like profound resonance.
And we were like,
wow,
we really need to talk more about what's happening because I think there's like
a world of mom blogs and there's this perception issue of people being like,
this is me and my perfectly swaddled clothed child and I'm doing great.
And the reality of that women everywhere are struggling.
And then the whole,
the psychological part came in through Birndorf and the spectrum.
Um,
and we had a mom at goop who was really struggling,
just,
she wouldn't mind me sharing that,
but just like extreme panic attacks.
She had had anxiety before,
she was great at,
during her pregnancy and then was not postpartum depression,
but like OCD,
anxiety to the extent that she was like,
I'm certifiable.
Like I need the hospital.
I need like function could not function.
And so Birndorf quarterbacked her to function,
say she's doing great,
doing great.
So that's sort of the lungs.
It was just like,
this needs to be something that we talk about truly filling a void.
There isn't anything else.
There's nothing that's incredible.
There is,
there are individuals out there,
I have colleagues across the country who are doing this kind of work who are
amazing,
who are in the field of reproductive and perinatal psychiatry,
psychology.
But they're all sort of individuals.
I mean they tend to be in big cities like my good friends in La and Chicago and
New York,
but they're not there that we wanted to create a center community where this,
um,
where we could really be the experts in this and try to figure it out.
I mean,
we have a lot of creative space to do.
We're a startup so we really,
you know,
we were a group of passionate clinicians who came together or trying to fill a
need,
you know,
sort of what,
solve for something that is missing because we weren't getting it done in the
eye.
You don't,
I come from the academic world.
The ivory tower can't even,
people will say to me,
you know,
my phone number on the Internet is still from when I was a resident for an hour.
So it's like ridiculous.
You can't even get into the,
you know,
so it's,
it's hard.
It's a very fort trust world out there.
Medicine at,
you know,
you know from it,
from your family.
But like if you don't know someone in the field,
it's very hard to break in.
Yeah.
And then you get to mental health,
forget physical health,
hard enough mental health.
And that's why may this month is so important to talk about it.
I mean,
nobody wants to talk about this.
The fact that you'll even say like,
you had this hard time postpartum is novel.
Yes.
Celebrities are coming out.
They're talking about it.
Um,
which I think is great.
It's definitely,
the word on the street is,
it's out there.
But again,
it's getting mistaken as,
oh,
it was,
I didn't have depression.
I didn't have that postpartum depression.
It used to be,
I would say five,
10 years ago when I would get calls,
it would be like somebody killed their child.
Right?
Right.
So,
and everyone thought that was postpartum depression.
That's not,
that's not,
that is postpartum psychosis.
When you lose touch with reality and you have these thoughts that like you're
saving your child if you kill them because you're so bad.
These are delusions.
This is a person who is out of touch with reality because I always say no mother
in their right mind would hurt their child.
Right?
That's not so,
so no one talks about it because they're like,
oh,
if I tell anyone,
I mean,
there was a Sacramento story not long ago where a woman told her,
uh,
I,
you know,
someone in the pediatrician's officer obese office and they called the cops and
then the car,
then it became a,
you know,
or acs comes in,
adult child services.
No one knows what's going to happen if they admit that they're struggling,
they think they're going to think I'm a bad mom.
They're going to think I'm a bad person,
that I might try and hurt my kid.
Like those horrible sensationalized news stories I've heard about it.
So the fact that we're having just a,
you know,
a conversation about routine stuff that I cannot,
one in five women struggle.
So and,
and dads too.
It has to be under reporting.
I total it.
Well the numbers one in seven,
I go with one and five cause for sure.
Yeah.
It's underreported underdiagnosed undertreated,
yeah.
And dads too.
Yeah.
I think it's amazing.
And this is,
um,
moving a bit away from other hoods center,
but obviously tangentially tied to it and somebody else that was on goop and the
clarity cleanse.
So wonderful book.
You haven't read it.
I forget the author's name.
Yeah.
And he was actually at the first goop summit.
I'm a good fan.
I can tell.
Um,
next summit is in three weeks to ninth be there La.
Uh,
but he talks about actually that mental health and physical health are the same
thing.
Yeah.
And so while we're still working to get there and de stigmatize that mental
health.
Yep.
All of that is so closely tied to everything inside your body.
And so if you're on to something from the past,
mentally there will be a physical manifestation of it at some point.
There's a great book by,
um,
a trauma expert.
Bessel van der Kolk called the body keeps the score.
Yeah.
I just love the title because I feel like it says it all right.
You don't escape your past and you don't escape your mind,
your body,
your trauma.
Everyone's got something that lives in the body and it will come to the panel or
other favorite parenting experts.
Robin Berman.
Yeah.
Um,
parenting becoming a parent creates a crisis.
Do you,
because it like forces every,
the way you were parented to the surface and suddenly it's like,
what kind of mother am I going to be?
What kind of othering did I not get?
Like just a total and yeah,
it's a crisis.
I don't,
and I don't think people are necessarily when they're not conscious of that.
No.
Sometimes you are,
I mean,
I think we with permission to pair,
which is a wonderful book if you haven't read it.
Um,
and you just happened to be the other's best friend.
And she's adorable.
Uh,
you know,
my husband,
I talk about this often with,
we try to create for our boys the opposite of what we had.
But as we're in the midst of seeing all of our friends also become parents,
it's very interesting because some of them just directly wants a copy that,
because they had such wonderful,
so they see him,
idyllic childhoods.
But it is,
it is an act of becoming a parent and you chose it the minute you got pregnant.
But it isn't something that is fully fleshed out in your brain until you start
seeing these little things run around.
And then there's this idea that it's all supposed to be natural,
right?
Like there is no act and you're supposed to know how to breastfeed.
And I mean,
these things that are not natural,
I'm sorry,
but the like,
um,
and,
and what's a natural birth?
And that conversation drives me nuts too.
Um,
it starts like the judgment starts.
Oh,
I mean,
what kind of birds are you going to have?
What I mean not to just,
I'm not in a complaint.
It's uh,
it's complicated.
And I also think too,
that's another thing about going back to once you're,
when you're pregnant,
you are the princess and once you have the baby or the peasant,
even with when you were had the lactation consultant come,
I remember,
I thought this was for me because I was,
it was so painful and so hard the first time.
And they're like,
nope,
nope.
All about the baby.
And like,
but what,
how do I know I can I get some help over here?
Literally they missed the boat,
missed the boat.
And again,
that's why what we're finding when these women leave the mother had senator is
they are repleted to go back to that depleted word.
They feel cared for,
nourished.
We do not do that for mom.
Now it's all about the baby.
You know,
you're celebrated when you're pregnant.
Right?
But the minute that kid out all eyes on the baby and great,
but what about the mom?
Yeah.
And I hope there is a shift.
I mean,
at least,
again,
in my small circle,
we always do when,
when a baby's born,
it's not about holding that new baby.
It's where's your laundry and where,
what can I do for you?
Because I will marry Poppins this because,
right.
That's selfishly would I would like to have.
Right.
So,
but it is you,
you don't know until you know,
and it's,
but how do we educate,
so obviously motherhood center,
but at least what other opportunities are out there,
I guess opportunities,
the wrong word,
but what other things are in place for women to go to and get this sort of
resource?
Obviously,
you know,
if we can't all be in New York City,
which has Googlers,
we're lucky because we potentially do work in New York and we can visit and we
will.
But you know,
for those of us who can't,
you know,
digitals key right now.
So what,
what,
what resources are out there?
Well,
I think it,
of course,
other than games and
hopefully more motherhood centers,
um,
to,
I mean they're,
I,
I wouldn't,
it's hard to say.
I mean,
I'd say it's piecing together things that work for you.
It's an a lot of it.
It's like the metal.
It can learn a lot from the airline industry.
Like you have to put the oxygen mask on yourself first before you help other
people.
And I think it's,
it's a familial conversation.
I think it's a forced conversation with partners too,
of like,
I need to be a priority,
I need to be as prioritized as my child.
Um,
and that needs to be a social conversation.
That needs to be like cultural conversation.
Um,
of,
you know,
we were talking about this before.
I'm married to a really lovely man.
Um,
he's great.
He is far less stressful career and he's a,
he's a really good dad.
I still do 60% of the work.
Um,
and he is applauded.
Like he's celebrated as an amazing dad cause sometimes he drops her kid off at
preschool and you know,
he puts on that bad.
Yeah.
And like I am not celebrated.
I'm an absent mom.
Um,
even though I do more of the work.
And so it's,
it's even just bringing awareness to that.
And then I think in order for things to change,
it's connecting with women who are not yet mothers because nobody knows.
Like I just was shocked.
I was,
it was before it was like cute.
But when I had my first child and I was eight months pregnant and I went to the
benefits office for my midterm and I was like,
oh,
so I'll be on maternity leave.
And she's like,
okay,
so you're going to beat,
you'll be,
and this was bad.
This is far better than the vast majority of Americans.
Like what?
We're going to pay for six weeks and then you go on disability.
I was like,
I can't survive on disability.
Like what are you talking about?
Like I thought I had a 12 week leave and I think,
you know,
a 27% of women are back at work two weeks after having a baby because they have
no family leave.
And then you start this whole cycle.
Yeah.
Oh,
pernicious cycle.
And I was furious.
Yeah.
I was so mad.
Not only at my company,
but also at the culture.
Um,
and like,
that's not a good way to start.
That's not a good way to become a mom either.
No,
it's not good for anyone.
It's funny,
I was a resident when I had my first kid who's now 19,
and I didn't know what I got either.
And I'm like,
I didn't even know if there's maternity leave.
I was one of the few residents to get pregnant during residency in those years.
And I went in and I'm like,
what are like,
what's the deal?
And they said six weeks and if you have a c section,
you'll get the,
this is at a hospital,
right?
I mean,
it's so ironic,
you know,
it was dismal.
Well,
I will say to Google's credit,
you guys,
when we do it right,
you have an incredible maternal maternity and paternity leave policy.
Um,
and for those of you thinking about getting pregnant and thinking,
I don't need all that.
You need it all.
Take it all.
There's never a day.
You'll wish you didn't do that.
Um,
but we also,
when I said when I opened this talk,
we have the expectation when you're working here is incredibly high and it is so
difficult to be a mom and have all those expectations.
So I agree with you that it starts with women who haven't had children.
And I,
you know,
I have a lovely manager and he's so responsive to my needs.
I forced it because I always have these conversations with him,
but not everyone is like that.
Um,
but I find it to be a little trickier with peers who don't have children.
So what,
I mean,
I'm sure you've seen New York City,
you've got to have some high powered ladies coming in there with,
so what is some advice to help,
you know,
moms in high power jobs deal with women that don't have kids who may want to and
it's no one's fault,
but it is an interesting place to navigate,
um,
with when you get that call yesterday and my son,
we had to take him to the doctor unexpectedly,
a 2:30 PM.
And so I had to work from home and you know,
you get some,
it's very difficult.
Well,
it's a,
it's a systemic issue.
Yes.
And we look at it as the mother's problem.
Yeah.
Um,
I'm not sure if dads are running home or you know,
as much or partners are running home,
but the primary caretaker,
whoever that is,
typically the mom is really disadvantaged,
which should not be the case.
This is a fan.
I mean,
do we want to populate this country?
But you know,
but so isn't this everyone's issue?
Isn't it a natural thing?
So why it's considered,
um,
a problem,
you know,
when everyone's hide,
can you cover for me while I run out?
It's like what?
Yeah.
So again,
it's hard,
but I think that,
um,
it has to be a community of familial,
but you have to,
it it's,
it's a,
it's a cultural systemic issue.
And you're right.
Even yesterday,
I kind of coward when I said,
well,
I've got to take him to the doctor because he might have bronchitis
or your partner should be able to go that shit.
That's normal.
Yeah.
Normal.
Where we're using that word.
But I,
and you're right.
I mean,
but it is difficult for people,
but I think the verbiage around it is so important.
Well,
I think,
and I think it honestly,
it's an issue that needs
to start with like with men.
I think to start that one,
they have like when you look at the research,
they have the power to advocate change and I think they feel shy about it.
Like it's a woman's issue and it's not really my place,
but they're the,
it's,
it's sadly going to be the most,
well there they can,
it's a numbers game.
It's a numbers game.
Like women and minorities when they advocate for themselves are,
it's not,
it doesn't always go well.
Um,
men when they advocate are seen as like big hearted.
It's positive.
So men need to start advocating for it.
Um,
they need to make sure that there are women in the room.
they need to model it and make sure that the environment is one that is sort of
ideally,
and this is,
this is it only works at places like you'd been Google,
but that they're setting reasonable work hours and not inundating people on the
weekends and letting w mothers in particular do their work when they can do
their work.
I mean if you want something done,
ask a mom.
I don't know anyone who falls down on that,
but it has to start,
it has to be that sort of conversation.
Do the men take it?
I'm wondering at Goop and I googled do they take maternity or paternity?
Cause I think that that's another issue is that there,
oh,
they'll take a week or two.
And again,
I don't mean to stereotype,
but are they modeling it?
Are they taking it or are they seen as somehow weak or if they actually do
music?
So I don't know the stats on that.
I'm sure we can get it.
Um,
but I do know that my,
my husband,
you works for a different Tech Company and he did take his two paternity leaves.
Thank you very much.
That's a gift.
Will certainly never want to give back.
And um,
I know my brother in law works at Google and he'll be taking his paternity
leave.
So it's certainly is becoming encourage.
It's certainly in the,
or encourage you guys are cutting edge.
You are leading the way.
But even for us and I,
I'm much more,
I'm glass half full,
so I see us as being,
it's such a wonderful experience and the amount of time we get off.
But even,
you know,
two weeks ago when my son was two turned one,
um,
there was a gal in Canada who I was chatting with and her son also just turn one
and she just got back from maternity leave and she too works at Google.
So it is very interesting.
Um,
and I certainly am so happy to have what we have,
but it,
it isn't perfect.
And what is the right amount of time for a woman to have off is obviously
different per woman,
but should we should have a larger spectrum.
Yeah,
that's the thing.
I mean,
I'm in some ways not maybe a good representative,
but when I had my second child,
it was,
this'll,
this'll probably drive you crazy.
Um,
it was,
it was an incredibly busy time and I just brought him to work.
I stayed home for six weeks and then I just brought my baby to work for eight
weeks,
I think.
And it was awesome.
Okay.
Medicaid?
No,
everyone loved it.
I mean,
he just was like the office baby.
He'd be napping and everyone's arms.
I nursed him at work.
Yeah.
Um,
and sure.
Like if it hasn't been a different time,
I would have stayed away for longer.
But that worked for me.
And that would also works for me is I don't,
I,
if I need to go to the doctor,
I go to the doctor without guilt.
Okay.
Or I,
I work,
uh,
he goes to a co op nursery school,
so I work at the school one day a month,
et Cetera,
at like,
that's what I need is prolonged and constant flexibility.
That's the word.
Yeah.
And I get,
I definitely get my job done,
but it has to be within the confines of the flexible.
And I,
I'm fine with that for my whole team,
many of whom are not moms.
I'm like,
I don't care if you are in Alaska and your work is done like
fine.
Yeah.
More power to Ya.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
Flexibility is certainly key.
So before I open it up to Q and a,
because I'm sure a lot of people have questions and we have some questions
that'll be coming from online.
My one of my last questions is how do we de stigmatize or normalize,
you know,
postpartum anxiety or postpartum depression,
how,
how can we make it a more welcome environment for women to talk about it not
only at a center or you know,
behind closed doors with their managers or girlfriends.
Um,
is it simply just talking about it?
Is it men talking about it?
Is it women without children talking about it because they've seen it?
Yeah.
Talking,
talking,
talking cannot talk enough about it to start to help people feel to normalize
the,
uh,
the transition.
But it's hard to validate their varied experiences.
It's different for everyone,
but talking is key.
And,
and,
and in a nonjudgmental way,
right.
There's no judgment,
Whether you work outside the home or work inside that,
wherever it is,
you can't,
people are different and we want to respect their different experiences.
Visa,
VI,
Motherhood,
parenthood.
And so just in a way,
just being curious,
asking like,
how's it going for you?
I always say,
um,
you know,
doctors don't like to not know answers and they'll say,
well,
I don't,
I don't ask women about postpartum anxiety or depression because I don't treat
it like I'm not the expert.
Like you,
I don't know what to do.
And I said,
Oh God,
we have a long way to go.
Yeah.
But you don't have to know what skills to what questions to ask.
Just look them in the eye,
hold their gaze and say,
how are you and don't move.
Yeah.
And look at them.
And often people burst into tears.
No one's asked how I am.
Yeah.
Right.
It's all about this cute little baby.
Yeah.
Right.
But you gotta just look someone in the eye,
just have a real conversation,
not like,
hey,
how you doing?
Oh,
it's great.
Right,
right,
right.
Yeah.
Just like have the conversation,
just have a real conversation.
I absolutely love that.
And I was talking to a teammate of mine about something very similar with just
ask,
you might feel uncomfortable,
you might know what know what to ask,
but just do exactly what you said.
Yeah.
I,
um,
a few months ago I was listening to the Oprah Winfrey podcast and she was
interviewing Cheryl Sandberg and this is,
she was talking about,
you know,
obviously your husband died and people were,
it's trepidation circling the issue.
And she said,
I'm always thinking about it,
right.
So you can always ask me.
And while this being coming a mother's that much happier thing,
but you can always ask me how I'm doing because I'm always thinking about my
children and you know what to say.
That's fine.
You can even say,
I don't really know how to ask you this,
but,
um,
I know you're a cop.
Like,
yeah.
How you doing?
Yeah.
And you don't have to know the answer,
you're going to Google it.
Yeah.
Um,
on occasion for meetings where we run,
we just quickly go around the room when people say either personal and work or
combination or however you want to do it.
Are you red,
yellow,
green,
and it's very helpful just to one.
And people can explain or they don't have to explain.
But I think it also in any contact,
it gives greater context to any interaction of just like,
I might be red because maybe I was up all night with a sick kid and then I might
not be in a great mood and it's not you.
But I think it also creates like a,
it's,
it's important,
you know what happens at home and yeah.
The two are so intermingled now.
Yeah.
And also at home when you get home.
With asking your partner.
Yeah.
You're going to be red,
yellow or green.
Um,
okay.
Any questions
and the audience.
Okay.
Too Shy.
We've got some on the door.
He just answered everyone's,
I know we have lots of coming,
so,
okay.
First one on here.
What can husbands do to support their spouse when they're suffering from
postpartum depression even later when my wife seems to have come out of it but
isn't 100% of her earlier self.
Can I do anything to make her feel better outside of the medical help she is and
was getting?
Great question.
Awesome question.
Um,
I think you can ask.
I,
you know,
people don't often or won't volunteer what they need,
but I'll often say,
you know,
we're not mind readers ask like,
how can I help you?
What can I do for you?
And observe,
see what she's struggling with.
Where are areas in which you can be helpful?
But you know,
um,
you may not know,
you know,
the love languages,
you may not know what her,
what would feel cared for for her and vice versa.
So you asking,
so what can I do to help you?
You don't seem entirely yourself.
What am I missing?
What are we not doing here?
Are you getting,
you know,
are you,
are there ways in which you can help her get to the help she needs?
Is she getting mental health help,
you know,
um,
is that being,
are the or the needs being met?
Because you know,
you can feel with,
with,
with proper treatments,
um,
everyone feels better and everyone gets well and a lot of times women will say,
I feel even better than I ever felt because maybe they were,
they had a simmering depression or they've always been sort of chronically
anxious and it didn't come to light until they were postpartum and then it just
blew up.
So I think sometimes with proper treatment you really can be the better.
So if,
if that's not the case and continue to persist,
don't ever give up.
If you feel like,
um,
your wife's come out of it,
but it's not quite that,
just,
just don't give up,
keep pushing until you get to a place that feels right,
feels comfortable.
Hmm.
Great question.
Okay.
Uh,
coming back to work with postpartum depression is very hard,
but oftentimes colleagues don't know what they can do.
What would you recommend for manager colleagues to do to help?
That's a really good questions.
I wish I could ask that.
Pr,
you know,
I don't know if they can hear me or,
wow,
okay.
Um,
um,
do people know,
I mean that's the thing or are are you who's asking this question,
you know,
willing to share.
Again,
I don't,
you know,
we're sharers up here clearly.
Um,
but,
and I don't know that you have to give all the details,
but I think if you're willing,
again,
this is part of what brings it out is to say,
you know,
I struggled to put,
you don't have to give it,
I struggled or I'm struggling and then your manager,
you know,
and then you can think about ways to assist your manager helping you.
It would be great if you could help me with,
or if I could run out to a pediatrician or appointment or,
you know,
what,
I'm actually getting treatment for my blank.
Would it be okay with you if I left for these appointments?
Right.
You have to ask,
you have to ask.
Um,
and you have to teach.
You have to help people help you.
So I think that,
um,
if you're willing to share,
and again,
you don't have to go down to the,
the TMI rabbit hole of every detail,
but just,
um,
I,
I've been struggling,
so,
um,
you know,
would it be okay if right at anyone who says no to that?
I mean,
yeah.
Yeah.
Great question.
Um,
could you recommend lifestyle best practices,
specifically diet,
nutrition,
supplements,
exercise,
et Cetera,
to help replenish mom?
That's you.
You're the clean of that.
I know.
I have the doctor on that lifestyle.
Yeah.
Um,
so generally,
um,
my advice would be to ask,
get your doctor or go,
what's it called?
One O one medical here.
Um,
you know,
again,
fortunately for us,
Google has amazing benefits and one medical is now our wellness centers,
so I'm sure you're going to say get your panel testing at your panel testing and
you can do,
yeah.
So most likely,
I mean omega,
so like really good fish oil.
You can't really take too much of that.
Vitamin D,
vitamin B,
magnesium,
iron.
I'm like,
that's probably baseline.
And then you have,
Yep.
Get,
get your hormones checked,
make sure your thyroid is functioning,
um,
and you'll want to work with your doctor to address it or tinker with it if it's
not.
Cause that can a lot of autoimmune disease flares up postnatally for women.
Um,
and you want to,
you want to curb it.
There's sort of this autoimmune spectrum that a lot of doctors are starting to
talk about.
Like you don't get that diagnosis of Hashimoto's until you've essentially your
thyroid.
But there are a lot of things you can do in the interim to help.
Um,
exercise.
It's really hard.
Exercise is really hard for new moms.
Like you're nursing,
you're leaking your incontinent.
Um,
it's so awesome.
And um,
I'd say I would try to find someone who can really help you with your pelvic
floor.
I am from goop guys.
Um,
and,
and Europe,
it's like mandated.
You get an APP,
you are,
um,
they are getting your pelvic floor back into shape.
But I would definitely focus on that cause it can,
you don't want like a prolapsed uterus or bladder later in life and you
definitely want to be able to hold your pee.
Um,
you can jump on a rebounder too.
That's really helpful.
But there are a lot of physical therapists who will work on your pelvic floor.
Um,
and also help you like for me,
because I came to cube after I became a mom,
like a year out,
I went to work with this woman,
Lauren Roxborough does a lot of foam rolling content with us and I was still
holding myself like I was pregnant,
which is very common,
but just this like I looked pregnant and so she,
I,
she got me back into alignment,
which you can do through [inaudible] or physical therapy.
Um,
but your organs are all back and stuff and your body will come back but you can
help.
There are a lot of things that you can do to help.
I am by no means the expert,
but do read a lot of content.
And I would say,
you mentioned Alejandro Hunger,
who eight years ago significantly changed my life.
My mom has an autoimmune disease,
which is what brought me to this whole wellness thing.
And I'm doing the clean every year I think is so important.
And I know it's so hard to get your mind over not being able to,
for me drink alcohol,
I'll just wind,
but you know,
drink a little bit of wine and have a piece of pizza,
but it's 21 days.
You can certainly do it.
So you have given birth,
you can do a 21 day cleanse
two and it's nourishing.
It's not about deprivation is not a calorie thing at all.
You can shove as much stuff into your smoothies,
you can snack if you're hungry,
but it's that filling.
It's all about eliminating potential things that might be aggravating you.
So it's also really good if you need to know,
like,
am I tolerant of gluten and my tolerant of dairy?
Um,
but,
and there are supplements that go with it for after my first one,
it was,
it profoundly shifted me and it reset.
I didn't lose,
I lost like two pounds when I did it 21 days.
And then after I just dropped all my weight,
it was weird.
It just reset me.
Um,
but I agree it's also,
it's two shakes,
breakfast and dinner and it's actually really nice not to have to make dinner
for 21.
Yeah.
And yeah,
he's just wonderful.
He has a lot of different resources out there too.
So for Diet I would,
I would strongly recommend his stuff.
Yeah.
Um,
and then for exercise too,
what I found after my second w especially right away was it was very hard to get
out,
especially finding classes.
I'm a class person,
I love orange theory and Barre method and [inaudible],
but how do I get there if he's supposed to be nursing at that time and they're
preset.
So I'm a big bar method fan and if you like bar,
um,
I really,
really believe in it during pregnancy.
Um,
it just keeps everything tight and nice and it's not too strenuous on you,
but it,
um,
they have on online classes and they're just as good.
I swear it,
I'm not the type of person who can work out at home.
And this has really changed for me,
especially because I travel for work and glow.
I think you guys have
program with them.
They're good.
There are a lot of good streaming.
It's a good idea.
Yoga glow.
Tracy Anderson.
Yeah.
Forest and it's good.
So I just say walking.
Yeah.
I mean I live in New York City.
You can walk to a door and you know,
just like locking,
like get those 10,000 steps.
I'm so basic.
I can't
shut that baby on.
Yeah.
Okay.
Um,
I had significant postpartum depression and took short term disability leave
after my maternity leave.
Do you have advice for sharing or not sharing with colleagues?
Why?
I was on leave for so long.
My colleagues assume I extended my maternity leave and was lucky quote unquote
when my experience terrible to some,
fight them to stay home with the baby.
[inaudible] the best scenario.
Yeah.
Um,
you know,
I think that's very personal.
I think you have to decide how much you're willing to put yourself out there.
And again,
I don't think you have to give all the information,
but um,
you know,
if you're sensing that people feel kind of um,
are looking at you kind of like,
ah,
you know,
you will be extra maternity leave,
you,
you might,
if you have the opportunity or maybe you make the opportunity to address it and
say,
you know,
I had a really difficult time.
I,
my extra leave really had to do with kind of a medical issue.
Again,
postpartum depression is a mental illness is medical.
So this is a medical problem and when I write notes,
I do a lot of,
uh,
you know,
letters for disability.
Um,
I may be a psychiatrist but I,
these are medical problems and it has to be addressed as such and considered as
such.
And I think sharing that you had a medical problem,
you know,
which was why you were out.
You don't have to go into the details.
You don't,
again,
you,
you can choose how much you want to share.
But I think reconceptualizing this as a medical issue is important because I
think that lets us off the hook.
Like,
I'm not just weak or,
um,
defective,
but this is really,
it's a real thing and you can say as much or as little,
but I think that's up to,
to how much you're willing to share and yeah,
it's so hard not to be ashamed by it though.
Shame is,
I know.
How do we get rid of that conversation we're doing and brave that bull.
I think stepping up and saying this happened to me and like,
let's talk about it.
Um,
you know,
I know celebrities are doing it.
Yeah.
I think the more we bring it into general conversation,
the better.
Um,
and recognize that it's,
that it's a difficult time for anybody.
It's not love at first sight.
I mean,
sometimes it is,
but a lot of times it takes a while before you kind of fall in love with the kid
or know what to do or feel comfortable.
I mean,
do you have like postpartum?
Like are there support groups here?
I don't know.
Yeah.
Ooh,
excellent.
Not what do we have a go link for that or sorry,
getting the benefits.
Okay.
Momma mom support group.
It's so important to find a cohort.
And I think that,
um,
it's very validating and then the shame level goes down because you're like,
you had that,
you feel this way.
I mean,
because you know,
it's hard to do and it's hard to be in the part.
I always say women in the park,
they don't mean to lie,
but,
or Instagram,
whatever,
everyone looks good.
So it's hard to sort of break through that veneer of,
of what you think you think everybody else has it easier,
better,
they know what to do and they're just as terrified and unsure and um,
how tired and how you get the conversation going.
So when you have a mom's group,
um,
hopefully it's a group where there's honesty and authenticity where you can
really share and validate each other so that you can say,
yeah,
it's really hard.
[inaudible]
you know,
I think too,
I'm look very vocal and out what I like about my experience as a mom and,
and I feel like people need to talk about it so that two people who are pregnant
or thinking about it and being like,
there's just so,
I mean like I was so mad at my friends when I had the beat my baby and I was
like,
why didn't no one telling me this?
Like any of this you want to scare you?
Moraines and oh like just you're like heads up.
Like I could have yeah.
Like sorry.
But that goes for the emotional amen.
No one talks about it.
And so you are left again and shame.
Yeah.
I always say I give the Tux Bolt.
We'll do,
see even Chrissy Tiegen just posted right after she had the second baby.
Um,
Asian pear underwear.
So the Little Mesh netting sometimes you see on pears should picture of herself
with the hospital underwear on.
And I mean the comments on it,
we're just,
yeah,
that's actually,
I'm,
I have a coauthor and I are writing a new book.
How come?
No one told me.
Because that's the reframe.
Yeah.
Um,
and it has,
it's the emotional side of pregnancy and postpartum and because no one talks
about it.
So the idea is let's,
all these questions are actually answered in the book.
We talk about beef,
you know,
from the minute you're pregnant and sort of like what you don't know and what
you need to know.
It's like the need to know stuff,
what to expect did for the physical we want to do for the emotional.
Um,
and that comes out in a year.
Next Mother's Day.
That's right.
Everybody get planning on that.
I always say I,
I'm certainly,
you know,
somebody that folks come to when they're about
to get pregnant or they did give,
you know,
and I've got the whole email and everything.
I tailor it to every single person.
But I always started off with saying,
oh,
it's the best.
It's the worst,
but it's the best.
And that's the pendulum swing some days really quickly in between those two
things and sometimes stays for longer and the euphoria.
But it is,
and the people care to ask.
I will say,
you're right.
It's the best.
And here's why it's the worst,
but
oftentimes people don't always want to know
well,
and can they retain it?
That's the other thing.
I always wonder because when I used to go give lectures to the new parents
group,
I would,
I had to bust my way in in the hospital.
I would say like,
can I come and just give a little preview of what postpartum might be like?
And they're like,
no,
because we don't want to scare those people.
Really tell people what it,
what it could be like and not think of that as,
you know,
like I felt like the grim reaper as opposed to just like this.
Just information.
Yeah.
Just being honest.
Okay.
Um,
at almost nine months postpartum,
I still feel a loss of time with my hello little one,
little one off.
When I'm at work,
what can I do to feel better about being at work?
Trying to rationalize it.
I need to work for my family,
but it's not helping with the sadness of lost opportunity.
Costs time with my baby.
I know.
Sense.
Yeah.
It's hard.
It's,
I mean,
but it's also,
I'll just talk about how I think about it there myself,
which I also definitely need to work.
And I do love to work one I like,
I'm like the universe has created enough of a support network for me to be able
to work and I'm going to lean into that.
Like I love my nanny.
She is like my mother,
everyone's mother.
Um,
and so that makes me feel better that my child is surrounded by love,
but also I'm like,
I need to model,
like I'm going to model for my boys what it is to have a mom who works.
Like I,
I feel on some like spiritual karmic.
They chose me,
they get it.
Um,
and this might not be true of view,
but I am not,
like,
I'm not,
wasn't put here.
I'm not like a on the floor playing mom.
I've given my,
I've let myself off the hook for that,
but also,
um,
like I'm,
I'm good at work and I'm a good mom and it's not perfect.
It doesn't look perfect.
Um,
but I think it's like allowing for the messiness and allow like I have to let
yourself off the hook.
Um,
it's not lost opportunity.
It's like you are also having a life.
You're showing your kids that there's more outside of the world than them too,
which is important.
And I would add
quality over quantity,
which is cliche,
but very true.
Um,
or at least I tell myself that.
And it sounds like,
you know,
I mean it's important that when you're with,
when you're with them,
look,
if you're with them and you're lamenting the loss of time or you're having
regret when you're with them or you're so guilty when you're with them,
then there's a different problem,
then you got to address that.
Right?
You're not able to put it aside and be with them.
So when you're there,
be there and when you're at work be at work and you can still be,
you know,
checking in,
but you,
you have to be present where you are and then when you're home with them,
be with them.
But if that's really,
um,
if that's hard,
then you have to kind of work through this because most people aren't home with
her kids.
You know what I mean?
This is in our country.
We two working families is the norm and um,
I don't think kids are any worse off because of it.
I think to your point,
modeling and showing them,
I remember so distinctly when I was,
um,
when my older daughter was four,
she was in the bathtub,
I was running to the hospital,
I was on call and I said,
ah,
I have to go to work.
I'm so sorry to leave you.
When she looked at me and said,
why do you say that you like your job,
you like it.
And I thought,
oh my God,
she just left me out.
She let me off the hog and I thought,
don't do this to my kids.
Don't make that like she's right.
I love what I do and I love to work and I love my kids and I love to be at home
when I'm at home.
But I would not be a good stay at home mom.
I'd be a disaster.
I hardest job,
the hardest job.
I have such admiration and the women who stay home and do this and want to do it
and love doing it.
Great.
It's just complicated.
You have to figure out the whatever the formula is for yourself and there's no
right,
wrong or perfection.
It's just you got to figure out what works for you and you are in your family
context.
Yeah.
But the guilt enough,
the regret,
the shame.
It's so wasteful.
There's a,
I went to this um,
moms group after I had my first and um,
she said something that was I really needed to hear and she was like,
think about your childhood and like your happiest memories.
And my happiest memories were like running wild in the woods with my brother and
I grew up in Montana and she was like,
how many of your happiest memories were your parents in attendance for?
And not that many.
Like,
I have amazing parents and there are present,
but like she's like your child unfortunately like,
like you are at the center of their world right now but like their life extend
far beyond you and you don't need to put yourself in the center of their story
constantly,
which like there have their own lives,
which is difficult.
It's coming kind of broke my heart,
but I needed to hear it.
And,
and I will say that we do have resources.
Um,
so if you are feeling still really down about it and missing your child's,
um,
you know,
to talk to your manager and talk about a flexible schedule if that's possible.
I agree with you.
We live in Barrie or in New York,
La to working,
you know,
to uh,
a double working household is very common and yet the culture hasn't kept up
with it.
I always say school ends at two,
but he's going to pick like pumps it into two.
What is this all about?
So,
you know,
as we,
as the things hopefully shift and change,
but you know,
there is flexibility at Google.
So hopefully you can
talk to your manager about it.
Let's do one more and then we can close things out.
Um,
so I know I want to do two more cause the next one looks really good.
Okay.
Can you speak more to how physical health and lifestyle behaviors impact mental
health?
No.
So intertwined.
Um,
I think that it's probably false that we separate.
Yeah,
absolutely.
And that's what the clarity cleanse is about.
So great question.
I would certainly read it.
Um,
but yeah,
no,
I think B,
vitamin B,
right?
I think you want to be physically well,
so,
um,
and not so stressed.
You want to minimize stress,
maximize self care,
taking care of yourself.
It's not selfish.
It is self preserving,
self nourishing,
like the oxygen mask.
You're no good to anybody else if you're not okay,
but you're no good to yourself if you're not physically well enough.
And I think that helps you be as mentally well enough.
Um,
again,
you don't have to be perfect.
Everything doesn't have to be exact,
but I think that,
um,
they're just so intertwined that,
that,
that you have to address both.
And I think that that becomes a problem because people,
you know,
everyone knows to work out,
go to the gym,
I'll be walking.
Everyone else would be in the gym,
but,
um,
but mental health has to also be addressed.
It's kind of like I said to someone the other day who said,
wait,
is therapy like Jim for your mind?
It's like going to the gym for your mind.
Yeah.
It's like brushing your teeth,
right?
So,
okay.
Not everyone's going to go to therapy though.
I kind of think they should.
Um,
I think almost anyone can use it because we all have passed.
We all have baggage.
We all have things to work out so that we don't revisit them on our children as
we're talking about.
Um,
and I think that,
that you want to be as well emotionally,
mentally as you can,
and that will help your physical health.
They,
they work in concert and to ignore one or to only focus on the other is
shortsighted.
Yeah.
And again,
with Google we have,
um,
look up,
oh,
go to Moma and look up concern.
We have programs that we can certainly,
um,
get therapy sessions and it's really helpful.
I personally use it and talk about it openly because I think it's so important.
And I,
there have been many times when I've been talking to my husband and like I'm on
my way to therapy.
I've nothing to say.
And then I leave.
Like this session I've ever had
just put a plugin for that.
It's not about the content,
it's about everything else.
So anyway,
so great question though.
And then last,
um,
you mentioned that this can affect dads too.
My husband has had severe depression,
severe depression and anxiety since the birth of our twins,
despite medication and therapy,
he feels very isolated.
What resources are available for dads and what can I do to help,
especially if I'm,
when I'm struggling myself.
Awesome.
Quick question.
Um,
one of my fellow board members at Postpartum Support International,
Danny singly,
this is his thing,
he's in,
um,
San Diego I think,
but he's Mr Postpartum Dad.
He's a great guy.
And he writes a ton about this.
And we also have somebody at the motherhood center,
Chuck Shaffer,
who works with the dads.
Um,
it's really important.
Again,
the dads who are struggling need a cohort,
they need other dads or other partners who are struggling and um,
they,
uh,
you know,
need the validation,
need the treatment.
It sounds like he's getting some treatment,
but,
but you need the resources.
So I'd say going back to that,
um,
postpartum.net,
the,
that's the website for postpartum support.
International dads are big part of it.
Families.
It's,
it's,
again,
it's about and started about moms,
but it's really families and now we've really,
we're big into dad's right now and to helping dads find the resources they need.
There's a,
um,
I think it's a weekly chat for dads online.
So you can be anywhere.
There's,
they're just great resources on the website.
So postpartum.net,
um,
Danny singly chuck Shea for,
these are some of the guys who are writing about it out there nationally and
there are others who do it.
But again,
search for your community and you can to the mom,
you know,
who's,
who's also struggling.
This is easy cause sometimes you can't even get online to look for it if you're
so down and out.
But so if you can find those resources,
just help him get to the resources.
Um,
a place like postpartum support international,
we'll take it from there.
We'll help you remember.
I think it's sleep deprivation as a,
as a,
essentially a mental illness.
Um,
and I think it's like puts everything in a different content.
I mean it creates crisis too and there's nothing,
it's sucks cause there's nothing to really do about it when you're trying,
when you have kids,
you don't sleep.
But I think even just remembering that in the back of your mind,
not permanent,
um,
that it's not permanent,
but that it is pernicious,
um,
helps in terms of like understanding what also might be going on.
Thank you.
All the people on the dory for asking these very personal questions.
Um,
I'm realizing why baby people in person didn't want to ask them questions.
He's number one is not as open as I am.
Just talking about all this stuff,
but a huge thank you to you guys for coming from La and from New York.
Every Thursday,
goop has a podcast.
Elise is usually hosting unless it's going to herself.
So I'm sure you have a lot of interesting guests coming up and there are some
other great podcasts that are in relationship to being a parent and um,
hormones and whatnot.
So please check those out if you haven't.
And then obviously,
Katherine,
thank you so much for coming and when I'm in New York,
I certainly am coming to the motherhood center no matter what.
And I would encourage other people into our New York Googlers who are listening
to go visit as well.
Yeah.
Um,
and is the best way to do that just to visit your website and is there an email
alias or pick up the phone.
Okay.
Yup.
Um,
you can call,
we have an info site and you'll get to a page Bambam who's our program director,
who will be happy to have you come and see.
Great.
And then a new book in next year.
A year.
Thank you guys.
Thanks everyone for coming.